dans la nuit du 5 avril 2025 les sirènes
retentissent ils tirent les habitants de
leur sommeil les lumières ne s'allument
plus internet et coupez le vacarme des
explosions se mêlent à celui des avions
de chasse qui décollent de leur base
cachés dans les montagnes la bataille
porte à one vient de commencer
ce scénario c'est celui d'une invasion
par l'Armée populaire de libération
chinoise face à elle se dresse les
forces armées de l'ancienne Formose
alors la question se pose que vaut
l'armée taïwanaise
quatre points permettent de juger
l'armée taïwanaise la doctrine le
matériel les Alliés et la motivation des
soldats
en ce qui concerne la doctrine cette
éclair pour les généraux taïwanais il
s'agit de se défendre face à une
invasion soudaine de la Chine par la
voie maritime c'est leur doctrine du
porc-épic on est sur une île qui est
complètement bunkérisée avec une défense
aérienne qui est très puissante c'est à
dire que tout appareil chinois qui va
s'approcher à moins d'une certaine
distance en réalité il est apporté de
tirs de la défense aérienne taïwanaise
cette doctrine du porc-épic Lille y est
contrainte son armée fait pas le figure
face à celle de son voisin continental
en effet la Chine dispose de près de 2
millions de troupes d'actives alors que
Taïwan ne peut en aligner que 170000
c'est 11 fois moins elle ne peut
également compter que sur cinq fois
moins de temps trois fois moins
d'artillerie 4 fois moins d'avion et 7
fois moins de navires que l'armée
chinoise
conformément à sa doctrine le
gouvernement de Lille a choisi de
concentrer ses forces dans l'aviation et
les missiles l'objectif est d'arrêter
les bombardiers chinois avant qu'il
n'atteignent l'île et surtout d'empêcher
une invasion par la voie maritime là les
combats au sol effectivement ça a
certains repas à l'avantage de Taïwan du
coup ils mettent tous leurs moyens dans
leur armée de l'air qui est très
puissante qui est bien organisée qui a
beaucoup de systèmes de défense et
également des missiles par centaines des
missiles anti navire et des missions
terriens qui sont répartis sur la
totalité de l'île ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la Force aérienne
de Taïwan elle est totalement orientée
sur la défense donc elle a beaucoup
d'avions de chasse de différentes
catégories par exemple les F-16
américains ils ont également des mirages
2000-5 qui sont des appareils
multimissions qui sont également très
modernes qui sont été livrés il y a
moins d'une vingtaine d'années ils ont
également un avion chasse locale qui est
dérivé du F16 le FC inca qui est un
appareil qui sont également à plus de
150 exemplaires donc au global en termes
de capacité de supérette aérienne de
défense ils ont quand même déjà
énormément il faut rappeler que Taïwan
n'est pas seul elle a des alliés en
premier lieu les Japonais mais aussi et
surtout les américains ils l'ont dit ils
défendront l'île quoi qu'il arrive
un scénario qu'il faut nuancer la Chine
pourrait décider non pas d'envahir l'île
de Taïwan elle pourrait simplement
décider un blocus ce qui limiterait la
réponse des États-Unis
enfin il y a la question des dépenses si
le budget de la défense chinoise a
dépasser les 250 milliards de dollars au
début de la décennie 2020 celui de
Taïwan n'a jamais dépassé les 20
milliards de dollars l'île n'a donc pas
les moyens de ses ambitions elle devra
donc compter sur sa ressource la plus
essentielle sa population comment
fait-on pour repousser un adversaire qui
sont plus puissant sur le papier ça
implique pas seulement d'avoir des armes
sophistiquées mais il faut aussi une
population mobilisée et donc toute la
question maintenant pour Taïwan c'est
comment mobiliser cette population
notamment la jeunesse pour qui la
défense n'était pas partie de sa vie
quotidienne désormais il y a une
perspective en bref il faudra livrer un
conflit asymétrique c'est-à-dire mener
des actions de résistance face à un
ennemi supérieur en tout point
ce qui suppose un changement de
mentalité des citoyens plus habitués à
la paix et à la prospérité plutôt qu'aux
entraînements militaires on est en
période de transformation en fait de
l'opinion
est-ce que on est prêt à changer son
mode de vie pour s'adapter à une
nouvelle donne géopolitique menaçant
chaque taïwanais doit se poser la
question est-ce qu'il est prêt à mourir
pour Taïwan ça c'est une question
dramatique
pourrait donc hésiter à faire l'ultime
sacrifice et c'est peut-être là que se
trouve le talon d'Achille des défenses
de l'île malgré une aviation de pointe
malgré des alliés puissants il n'est pas
dit que le moral des réservices et des
conscrits suffisent face à la vague
rouge qui menace de lait submergé donc
les stratégies chinois préféré que
Taiwan tombe comme un fruit mûr mais
pour ça il faut que la population
taïwanaise aussi
se décourage et c'est là où la garde
psychologique et capitaine elle se elle
a lieu actuellement maintenant elle a
déjà commencé
[Musique]